having been advertising having been
around the marketing world and working
for the stick ELA company sure been in
LA traveled do you think a filmmakers
should have their own marketing plan
like their own brand not just for their
films but for them 100 percent 100
percent filmmakers need to think about
marketing they need to think about the
brand of their product they need to
think about who's gonna buy their
product who's gonna watch their movie
now there's this relationship that you
have to build and it doesn't come right
away because if you've never marketed
anything before it's like two different
parts of your brain right you have to
look at it like why would someone choose
to watch my film just swiping through
iTunes or or even at a marquee in a
cinema why are they gonna watch your
film it's very hard to answer that
question for for yourself if you have no
practice marketing anything because
you're gonna be very subjective a bunch
of work it's art it's precious it's
yours
there's a there's a possession and a
permission to it that you know people at
different experience levels they have
different levels of control over the way
they hold what they make and it's very
difficult to step outside that ownership
of your work and look at it objectively
and be like does someone even want to
watch this right and so I think if
filmmakers expose themselves to
marketing plans and marketing objectives
it's not about that they're gonna become
a marketing executive right and they're
suddenly gonna they're suddenly going to
become jaded and they're not gonna care
about the passion of filmmaking and
that's probably the worry they're like I
don't want to study marketing because
it'll take away all of the magic right
but then you're also super naive about
the fact that you're not preparing
yourself for success because if you work
super hard and you
stay really incubated and you know
nothing about who's gonna participate
with your brand or your film you will
probably only get it make one because it
won't be successful you won't have
resources or if you have investors
they'll feel like nobody saw the film
it'll lose money so it's kind of there
needs to be a relationship where you
become familiar with the dance between I
have to look objectively at the work
because I am making it for an audience
which leads me to my next point I guess
which is eventually you have to
acknowledge an audience and I know
people who don't I know people who are
artists visual artists true and true I
know people who are screenwriters who
don't care about getting coverage or
they don't care about letting somebody
else to read their material who may be
objective or who may be critical and
that's great that's a hobby that's a
hobby that's not a professional a
professional understands the industry a
professional understands that it's a
marketplace someone wants what you made
or they don't and if you want to have a
career I suggest that if people are
really unfamiliar with branding and
marketing they try to understand it at
least that doesn't mean they need to
have a relationship doesn't mean they
need to go shoot ads but if they don't
understand it then they are cheating
themselves out of the possibility of
doing more work and so I think it's
super critical I guess the other thing
I'd say is that one of the things that's
happened for me transitioning from
advertising to features was that
relationship with an audience you know I
had opportunities for lack of a better I
had opportunities for lack of a better
phrase where I could get away with it I
could get away with pitching to a client
a highly artistic vision for a
commercial and they loved the idea so
much
that whether it sold a lot more watches
or athletic jackets or motorcycles they
love the idea so much that I wasn't
accountable to an audience now that's a
huge privilege it was a really great
opportunity but I didn't really know
that until I started to go into
developing the marketing plan and the
release plan for our feature because I
was like wait a minute what's my
relationship with his audience do I care
about my audience or not and do I even
have one I don't presume that anyone
looks me up or cares about me and maybe
that'll change someday but that's not
why I do what I do but I care about them
I was at I was at a premiere last week
doing a Q&A and the first thing I did
before I said anything or answered any
questions the person was very feverish
they really wanted to ask a lot of
questions and it was and it was cool
they were awesome but before I did that
I thanked everybody I said I said you
don't have cinema without an audience
you can have a film without an audience
because you made a film and it's just
there but if you try to throw it in the
theater and no one goes it's not cinema
because no one thought and so when I
said that out loud it was sort of like a
I was like the finishing of an arc of an
idea where I was like wow people paid
money to see my film and that doesn't
make me feel good from an egotistical
point of view I mean it doesn't make me
show bad but it makes me feel like the
idea that I wanted to understand why
they would want to see it felt complete
and in that moment very very personally
in that moment all I wanted to do was
make my next film
and finish it because I wanted more
audience members to see the next piece
of work and so I think there's a
relationship between marketing and
branding
and understanding that you have to have
an audience for it to be a high level
piece of work and and I hope people can
figure out their own relationship with
making art and marketing their art and
generally speaking it's a tough ask so I
would just say people should open their
minds
you